Oh
it's always a pleasure to be here I'm a
huge fan of heritage foundation
everything they do actually
when townhall.com was part of Heritage
Foundation they were the first outlet to
pick up my syndicated column I do have a
fourth book before bullies that was
primetime propaganda how the lefts
culture of fear and intimidation
silences America what we spoke here at
Heritage for that too I'm also the
editor at large of Breitbart news and I
host a radio locally in Los Angeles so
if you're bored or if you have an iPad
then you can tune in at Carraway 870
dot-com 6:00 to 9:00 in the morning
Pacific time 9:00 to noon here I want to
start off by talking a little bit about
Andrew Breitbart
I am the editor at large there Andrew
was a mentor of mine I met Andrew when I
was 17 years old he had just seen a
column that I wrote for the UCLA daily
Bruin and as he was want to do he was
sitting in like a greasy taco joint in
Westwood read the daily Bruin saw the
column and then promptly emailed me at
the time and who was just the secret
other half of the Drudge Report and we
got together we became fast friends and
one of the things that that you know
Andrew and I used to talk about a lot
because we knew each other for over a
decade before his untimely death was he
used to talk a lot about how the left
were a bunch of bullies now what the
left really does is try to shut down the
debate how their their sole goal is to
avoid a solid policy discussion by
trying to label us bad human beings
racist sexist bigoted homophobes and as
Andrews career went on I saw it happen
to him personally they obviously did
that to Andrew they tried to demonize
him as kind of a wild man right winger a
crazy person with fire coming out of his
ears Andrew was one of the most genial
people I ever met I don't know how many
of you met Andrew I'm sure some of you
did because there when Andrew died there
were probably a hundred million people
mourning him and 95 million of them had
at one point met or spent time or had
lunch with Andrew because that's who he
was but his his main message is that in
the main message of his life is that we
have to fight the bullies and that's
what being a conservative means is
fighting bullies the more I got to look
into his message the more I realized how
right that was and that's why I wrote
bullies in the last few years the left
has decided that the political debate is
worthless they're not going to debate
policy they're not going to debate what
is the best way to solve the
nation's problems they're not going to
private provide evidence they're going
to label us morally deficient human
beings unworthy of debate we see it in
virtually every arena of American life
in the last week alone we saw it from :
Powell we saw it from Brian Williams and
we saw it from President Obama himself
Colin Powell won on the sunday shows and
talked about the so-called dark vein of
intolerance that was running throughout
the Republican Party now what evidence
did he provide for that assertion that
were not left-wing that we don't believe
in anthropogenic climate change or that
we don't believe that there should be
redistribution of wealth or that we
don't believe in Obama care and if we
would just move to the left suddenly
that would make us not racist now :
Powell
above all should know how not racist our
party is considering so many in our
party we're considering supporting him
despite his liberalism in 1996 for a
presidential run and he was Secretary of
State under President Bush obviously
this is somebody who's treated very well
by the Republican Party but that didn't
stop him in any way because now Colin
Powell is on the left and that means
that we are the bad guys President Obama
did it in his inaugural address just
last week also he said there was a
peculiar line in his speech where he
said that absolutism is not principled
and he said that name calling is not
discussion he then proceeded to spend
the rest of his speech name-calling and
avoiding principal and and being an
absolutist he suggested that essentially
if you disagree with him you want people
in their twilight years to live in
poverty you want parents of disabled
kids to have no recourse you want the
poor to suffer you want black people to
stand in line to vote you want gay
people to be treated unequally and you
want women to be paid less than men
he actually said all of those things in
the speech and that was clearly the
undertone of his speech just yesterday
Dianne Feinstein gets up and she leads
off her whatever it was her press
conference she leads it off with a
pastor saying that if you're a good
Christian you have to be for gun control
if you're a good person you have to be
for gun control because otherwise you
don't care that kids are getting killed
all around the country in schools and
churches and places like Sandy Hook this
is what the left now stands for there
are several different kind of bullies
that it's worth pointing out I'm really
going to divide this into two sections
the first is I'm going to discuss what
it is that we face and the other part of
it is how we fight this because it is an
overwhelming
by the left to silence the debate to
shut us out from the debate and to cow
people into being quiet because it's
much easier to go about your daily
business not being called a racist
sexist bigoted homophobe who hates every
minority to begin they're the
institutional bullies now the right has
lost a lot of the institution's most of
my books are about institutions the
university system or Hollywood or the
media the reason that the write has lost
is because we think individually and the
left things institutionally we like to
debate people on one on one level will
go door to door will talk to anybody
will have a discussion with people on
that individual level whenever you see
somebody getting sucked into a facebook
conversation with a leftist friend who's
never going to be convinced it's always
a conservative you don't see leftist
getting sucked into these conversations
because leftist are too busy taking over
the media the left thinks
institutionally the left wants a
top-down dictation of policy they
understand something that we don't
because they think institutionally
because we don't think in terms of
top-down control and the left is fond of
doing so they think in terms of instead
of let's debate one on one will take
over the university system and then
we'll use it as a club to leverage
millions of young people to believe that
right-wingers are bad human beings or
will take over Hollywood and then we
will force everybody who is mildly
conservative out of Hollywood in order
to leverage our points of view down the
throats of the American people they do
it with regard to nonprofits too they
combine with the government look at what
President Obama just did in shifting his
campaign into a 501c4 lobbying group he
also opened the door by the way in an
executive order it's actually funding
that lobbying group from the government
president and President Obama is
somebody who really understands the
battle he understands the fight he's
very very smart and he understands that
he can use outside institutions like
Media Matters he can use outside
institutions like organizing for action
what was obama for america he can he can
use those institutions to push positions
he cannot do as presidents of the united
states he combines with those
institutions to push forward that agenda
and to silence people and to launch
boycotts and secondary boycotts against
anybody who disagrees we now live in a
country where if you abide by the basic
laws of economics you are an enemy of
this administration if you are Phil
Mickelson and you say the taxes in
California are too high I'm leaving then
you are told that you are somehow
a bad person there's something wrong
with you now there are a lot of people
who've left California because the taxes
are too high I'm paying those high taxes
I think every day about whether to leave
California because of the tax rate
that's because economics exists the left
doesn't think they do so when Wendy says
you know Obamacare is going to cost
money perhaps we'll have to cut back
hours and left response with if you do
that we'll boycott you that is not a
logical coherent economic argument that
is an argument that if you disagree with
the effects even of what Obama's
policies do with with what leftist
policies do then there's something wrong
with you you made a moral decision to
cut back those hour not an economic
decision to cut back those hours leaving
aside the institutional bullies for a
second there there are several types of
bullying that the left loves to engage
in their favorite of course is racial
bullying they love it it's their
favorite thing the reason for that is
that the left's philosophy is based
almost solely and completely at this
point on the idea that they stands up
for victimized groups everything they do
is to stand up on behalf of some
victimized minority blacks Jews gays
women doesn't matter if you're a
minority they're standing up for you
what that means is that if we oppose
their policies by necessity the logic is
we hate blacks gays Jews and women and
that is that is sort of the philosophy
that they tried out it also means that
they tray they treat people who are
apostates as though they're as though
there's something wrong with them
they're not if you're Jewish and you're
a conservatives I am you're not a real
Jew because that gives the lie to their
entire agenda if it turns out that not
all Jews agree with them then how can
they claim to be standing up for all of
these victimized minorities if Larry
elder is a black man and disagrees with
them then it's because he's not a good
black man he's not good at being a black
man he's betrayed his race that is the
philosophy of the left when it comes to
race now what they do the tactics are
really what's interesting here we all
know that they use the term race racism
far too often they label things races
that are not even close to racist voter
ID not racist but the left says that
you're a racist if you think that maybe
just maybe they should check the name on
the voter form with your ID to make sure
that you're not voting for Eric Holder
right I mean they they think that that
is a they think that that is a racist
thing what what they love to do their
favorite tactic though is to take a
single flashpoint incident use the media
to blow the
in select the biggest thing that ever
happened in the history of humanity
implied that all of America is based on
the same racism that caused this
incident and then say and the solution
to that racism is liberalism now one of
the best examples we saw that was last
year in the George Zimmerman case right
the George Zimmerman case was the
greatest case of media malpractice I
think in American history I mean the
only one that would even come close is
Walter Duran see trying to cover up
genocide in the Ukraine but but the the
attempt by the media a very clear
attempt to frame George Zimmerman really
frame him was it was obvious and it was
politically motivated
it was obvious what they were trying to
do what actually happened in the George
Zimmerman case is a Hispanic man was
trailing a black man that he thought was
engaged in possible criminal or
suspicious behavior he called 9-1-1 he
got out of his car when he turned around
and went back to his car he was
confronted by the black man who
proceeded to pound this man's head into
the ground until he shot him that is
what actually happened every police
investigation has shown that is what
happened there is nothing to contradict
George Zimmerman's account of events
there is not one shred of evidence to
contradict George Zimmerman's account of
events which is why he was released in
the first place
the media promptly turned this into what
jesse jackson termed it as white man
tracks down black man shoots him in back
of had he wasn't shot in the back of the
head who shot in the chest George
Zimmerman was severely injured in that
fight he was having his head pounded
against the pavement there were pictures
of it the way the media played it is
that George Zimmerman had never been
injured George Zimmerman was stalking
him for fun and just decided to shoot a
black guy for no reason
and they cut the 9-1-1 tapes to make it
look like that remember now NBC's being
sued because of that they took the nine
one one tape in which George Zimmerman
was specifically asked what is the race
of the person that you are following
he said he's black the NBC cut that tape
so that what it sounds like George
Zimmerman is saying is he looks
suspicious he's black they cut out the
entire exchange with the dispatcher he
had to be prompted for the race now the
reason that that mattered was that they
used this flashpoint incident as an
excuse to push liberal policy here's how
it works they send out Sharpton down
there to talk about how the Sanford
Police Department is massively racist
and that in general is just a symptom of
the unbelievable racism that pervades
America it's still a huge problem in
America racism happens all the time
as you know President Obama and many
others put it you there really
al sharpton did this a lot there there
and people in Congress walking on the
floor of the house hoodies when they
went the the argument that they were
making is that this is just one black
guy that this happens who it happens all
the time why people track down black
people and they kill them that's the
kind of country that we live in racism
is is just as bad if not worse than it
was back in 1975 this argument rose all
the way to the level of the presidency
right with the president saying that if
I had a son he would look like Trayvon
Martin which is eminently untrue Trayvon
Martin if you saw the current pictures
of him was tattooed Trayvon Martin's if
you saw the current pictures of him had
a grill
I highly doubt you're going to see Sasha
and Malia with tattoos or a grill any
time in the near future but the point
that Obama was making was that
essentially all black people are treated
the same by white people in this country
this is a racist country and therefore
if you don't believe in my political
prescriptions that's because you hate me
for the same reason that George
Zimmerman hated Trayvon Martin it's
because I'm black there is also a
secondary attempt here that was really
interesting there's a group called the
American Legislative Exchange Council
Alec big group a lot of corporations
fund it they push kind of quasi
conservative principles all over the
country one of the things that they had
push was something called The Stand Your
Ground law now you all remember with
George Zimmerman the media played it as
though George Zimmerman shot Trayvon
Martin turned around and said to the
police hey stand your ground you know
it's the law stand your ground
George Zimmerman didn't even know about
this I've talked with his family didn't
know about the Stand Your Ground law the
police didn't cite him then free him
under the Stand Your Ground law they
freed him because there was no probable
cause to keep him there but what this
was this whole all-out assault on The
Stand Your Ground law which is a law
that says that if you're attached you
don't have to retreat you can fight back
the whole point of that attack was to
leverage it against Alec which was an
institutional opponent of the Obama
administration Alec was big fan of voter
ID Alec had opposed many elements of
Obamacare and so Alex Alec had to be
finished and the way to do that was to
say that Alec was somehow responsible
for this murder this horrible racial
murder that happened in Sanford Florida
and by doing that they actually then
they went to Color of Change in media
matters and all these groups that we
mentioned before and they had them
leverage a boycott against Alec Alec was
so heavily boycotted that they had to
pull off The Stand Your Ground laws
completely they cut back on their voter
ID efforts and they were dissing and and
people actually pulled their money I
mean
pulled its money from them there were
there big corporations that didn't want
any piece of this and pulled their cash
the left is interested only in silencing
people with this sort of stuff that is
their main focus and then they again
they think institutionally they're very
clever what they're doing with this gun
control stuff isn't about gun control
they're not gonna pass one shred of this
what this is about is targeting the NRA
and demonizing the NRA so that that
institutional opponent goes away think
about it for half a second what did the
NRA have to do with Sandy Hook the
answer is nothing they had nothing to do
with Sandy Hook Connecticut is one of
the most heavily gun regulated States in
the country the NRA had not ridden any
of the legislation in Connecticut the
NRA is a privately funded institution
that receives no tax dollars I didn't
see anyone from the ACLU on David
Gregory being forced to explain why
violent video games are okay under the
First Amendment did you did you see
anybody being grilled from the ACLU
about that I missed it but they were
grilling the head of the NRA and saying
you need to change your position he's
the head of an interest group it's his
job not to change his position but the
left expects that he's going to and
they're going to demonize him until he
does because the NRA must be finished
this is their tactical maneuver we see
it on every front we see it from class
warfare on the fiscal cliff it turns out
that we don't want what's best for
Americans we just want to help rich
folks it turns out that you know when it
comes to sexual politics it's not that
we believe for a good reason in
traditional marriage for example it's
not that we believe that a child
deserves a mother and a father none of
that's true it's just that we hate gay
people and that makes us horrible and
inhuman and we're we're just terrible
human beings and we see it with regard
to God and secularism if you believe in
God and you believe that your values
ought to be expressed in the public
square in even the most minut way it is
because you are a thug who wants to hurt
people now what all of this does is it
justifies the most vile tactics on the
left I think a good example of this I
know how many of you saw my interview
with Piers Morgan on CNN appears is a
very good example of this
what piers does his tactic has always
been to go up there and then say that
whoever opposes him on gun policy he did
this to Newt Gingrich last night whoever
does this whoever opposes him on gun
policy it's because they don't give a
damn about the dead kids in Sandy Hook
it is a vile reprehensible disgusting
tactic and he uses it on a regular basis
but
it really is a microcosm of what the
left does on a regular basis I can't
remember the left the last time that the
left didn't use this tactic when
President Obama trots out seven-year
olds to stand behind him as he's
announcing gun control legislation and
then he puts on his wet on the White
House website videos of these same seven
year olds reading letters to the
president clearly written by their
parents and and this is supposed to be a
substitute for policy I'm unaware of the
point at which seven year olds became
the best guide to solving political
problems in this country if a 40 year
olds things like a seven-year-old
there's something wrong with them
and yet we are supposed to make policy
like a seven-year-old would so when you
have a little girl in a red dress
shouting into the camera no guns no guns
no guns no guns as President Obama does
we are supposed to take that at face
value
the left's entire tactic right now is to
trot out victims and then claim that we
hate the victims so that they can do
what they want to do so here's how you
fight this here's how you fight this
this is this is what I think it worked
well in the peers debate the first thing
that you have to do is we have to frame
our opponents we cannot be civil a
civility loses arguments civility does
not work we have been civil for the last
thirty years and we have been doing
nothing but losing the last time we were
uncivil was the Tea Party in 2010 and we
had a massive victory civility loses
civility is like the Geneva Convention
okay here's how it works here's how it
works if if you're in uniform that you
need a convention is designed to apply
to you right because that incentivizes
people to stay in uniform so that we can
distinguish you from civilians that's
the whole point of the Geneva Convention
once you get out of uniform then you're
done you're the Geneva Conventions don't
apply you have violated the rules and
the rules no longer apply to you if
you're gonna violate the rules you do
not get the benefit of the rules on the
other end the same thing is true of
civility if somebody is willing to sit
and have a civil conversation with you
be as civil as you want to be be
perfectly civil if somebody is going to
be a Piers Morgan type if they're gonna
be a bully if they're gonna be a thug
because these folks are thugs if they're
gonna do that then don't treat them
civilly that doesn't mean be rude it
doesn't do means you and Alex Jones and
start shouting randomly like a crazy
person what it does mean is that you
need to say things to them to force them
back into the mode of political
discussion if you'll notice what
happened with Pierre
is I let off the interview he said that
I said that he was off the rails which
is true I did say he was off the rails
men then he said why did you say that
and I said it's because you're a bully
and you stand on the graves of the kids
in Sandy Hook in order to push her
political agenda by implying that anyone
who disagrees with you is morally
deficient his comeback was how dare you
he clutched his pearls while he was
doing it the whole deal to which I said
that how dare you is not an argument and
then he said how dare you again he said
I repeat how dare you I said that's
still not an argument you know the the
fact is that you I've seen his show many
times and that's exactly what he does
now the reason I did that it was twofold
one was that it was fun
the other is that the other is that it
forced him not to use that tactic
because we're like think of the left
like magicians they are they're
magicians they don't have facts they
don't have evidence on their side what
they have is sleight of hand and they're
fantastic at it these are the best
close-up magicians that you have ever
seen it is our job to identify those
tactics and to sit in the back of the
room and be the guy who ruins the magic
show right worthy obnoxious fat guy in
the back of the room who watches all the
magic videos and we're just shouting at
the rabbit is at the bottom of that hat
and I promise you if you remove that
false panel there's a rabbit down there
right didn't get there by magic so so
what I so that that's what I was doing
the peers I was saying this is the
tactic you use the tactic by doing that
not only did I take that away from him
it was really interesting in the Saturno
if you watch the rest of the show after
that interview after I left he brought
out a kid who had been paralyzed in a
gun shooting and he started interviewing
this kid because this is what he does he
brings out we can have discussions with
with folks who have been shot and we can
try to fit we're all trying to figure
out the best way to prevent people from
being shot we all have good intentions
here it's disgusting that they imply
that we don't so you brought this kid
out he'd actually brought the kid out
between segments I had two segments with
piers first segment ends he's talking
frantically and his earphone with the
producer and and they're bringing up
boxes of sudafed for him to use as a
horrible prop and they also bring out
this kid and they put him in the
audience and it's pretty clear to me
maybe I'm wrong it's pretty clear to me
that they are planning to swivel the
camera around right so that after I make
this argument they're gonna swivel the
camera to the kid who's been paralyzed
in a shooting to pose the imagistic
contrast right here's this young guy
who's perfect
healthy and a gun owner and he doesn't
care about this kid who's been paralyzed
in shooting because I had said to piers
that he was going to do that he couldn't
do it it would have been too obvious to
everyone if he had done it I would have
immediately said to him piers you were
standing on the graves of the kids in
Sandy Hook now you're standing on this
poor poor person's wheelchair in order
to push your point and it's it's
disreputable and despicable so that's
the reason that it's important to debunk
their tactics and it was something that
it's something we have to be doing on a
consistent basis now the second thing we
ought to do is we need to frame the
debate one of the big youtuber Bowl
moments from that debate was when I
pulled the Constitution out on piers
when I reached into my pocket and I
pulled out a copy of the Constitution
and I handed it to him again number one
it was fun but number two I was handing
him the Constitution because it framed
the debate the vulnerability in peers
his entire world view is that he
pretends he cares about the Second
Amendment he does not care about the
Second Amendment everybody who knows him
knows he doesn't care about the Second
Amendment by pulling out the
Constitution I was forcing him to fess
up do you like this or do you not if you
like this Constitution then you have to
explain to me why you like the Second
Amendment and then explain to me how the
gun control proposals that you're making
don't violate that basic philosophical
injunction against imprint infringing on
the right of the people to their arms
right you need to reconcile for me how
you're Pro huge gun control and also pro
huge Second Amendment now he couldn't
answer that he you know throughout the
entire interview he could never answer
why he was for the Second Amendment and
when I mean when I forced him to be
consistent on his philosophy this is
really the third point right second
point is frame the debate by putting it
in constitutional context he had no
place to go the setting up the
philosophical inconsistencies of his
argument that's the third point once I
said to him piers you have no
philosophic basis for what you're doing
you say you want to get rid of assault
weapons because you want it because
they're killing machines well I'll tell
you a killing machine that kills way
more people it's called the handgun
you've said on the air that you don't
want to ban handguns so explain to me
how is it that you want to ban rifles
but you don't want to ban handguns why
is that do not care about the black kids
getting killed in Chicago is it just the
white kids in Sandy Hook that you care
about so forcing him to fess up to that
it meant that he couldn't answered
there's actually a point in the
interview where he says we'll get back
to that and then he just never comes
back to it the fourth point here don't
get
sidetracked again all magic is based on
distraction right I mean that's why they
have a pretty girl on the stage the the
point of the left and a lot of these
debates is to get people sidetracked
onto nonsensical issues in fact this was
the entire strategy of the Obama
administration I'll talk at the engineer
why would MIT Romney loss and it's
because he didn't do any of these things
the the reason that the left uses
distractions like binders and Big Bird
and all this kind of nonsense is that in
contraception is so we don't pay
attention to the fact the economy blows
okay the economy's horrible everybody
knows the economy's horrible and the
economy's not gonna recover anytime soon
so let's talk about condoms I mean
that's it that was essentially how the
left ran that campaign we cannot be
sidetracked by that we are always
playing defense because they because
they're saying you're a bad person the
natural human instinct is when someone
says that you're a bad person the
natural human instinct is to say no I'm
not I'm not a bad person why are you
saying that you know I'm not a racist I
have you know how can you call you know
no evidence for that what our first
instinct needs to be is to go on the
offensive they are the real racists for
defacing the term racism to apply to
things that are clearly and eminently
not racist when you if you took called
something a basic you know economic
policy anti-semitic and nothing to do
with Jews that's an anti-semitic move
because you're watering down
anti-semitism to apply to things that do
not apply when they are calling people
racist without any basis it's like the
boy who cried wolf what they're really
doing is they're making room for real
racists to be lumped into the category
of rational people who are full who are
for voter ID for example we can't be
sidetracked by that one of the things
piers did I mentioned the sudafed thing
earlier I thought we were gonna cook
crystal meth he took out like six boxes
of sudafed and put them on the table and
then he says here's the sudafed I wasn't
allowed to buy six of these at a time so
why should anybody be allowed to buy a
thousand bullets at a time which there's
no logical connection between the two
policies I mean I could be against I
could begin spoke policies I could be
for both policies I could be against one
and for the other and that's what I said
to him I said piers if you want to talk
drug policy I'll come back on we'll do
that if you want to talk gun policy why
don't we talk dad and he had no place to
go at that point because he wants to
talk about sudafed I mean as I said
later don't bring boxes of sudafed to a
constitution fight
which brings me the fifth point which is
don't be intimidated it's very
intimidating to be in rooms with a bunch
of liberals and we're going to have to
if we want to win the debate we're going
to have to go into hostile environments
it's not a bad thing it gives us an
opportunity to convince people don't be
intimidated by the thug tactics there's
a point in the interview late in the
interview where we're peers said you
know you do you understand how absurd
you sound you're absurd you're
ridiculous and I said to him Pierce
that's not an argument that's not an
argument if you want to come and bring
people on just so you can insult them
and avoid the argument that's cool I
understand that and I'm happy to be like
a scapegoat for you so you can abuse
people but if you actually want to have
a discussion you say you're serious
about this issue if you're serious about
this issue
let's talk not being intimidated is half
the battle because it's so easy to be
intimidated when someone calls you nasty
names it's easy to be intimidated the
only thing that you can do is to fight
back twice as hard six point here if you
don't know something admit it right off
the bat if you don't know about it admit
it right off the bat because this is how
the left likes to trick people what they
do is you're in the middle of an
argument and all of a sudden they change
the topic to something wildly off-topic
you're talking about the fiscal cliff
and suddenly you're getting a lecture on
why you hate gay people and then and not
only do you hate gay people here's a
letter signed and stamp from Ronald
Reagan showing that you hate gay people
you know and you've never seen it before
you don't know what they're talking
about this is completely random
information what are you saying the
answer to that is not to pretend that
you know the initial reaction is okay I
kind of know what you're talking about
you know just the human response the ego
is I know what you're talking about let
me try and deal with this say right up
front I don't know what you're talking
about and if you want me and you know if
you want to talk about it let me do the
research first and then we can have an
educated debate on the issue I don't
discuss things that I don't know about
it takes it off the table immediately if
it doesn't take it off the table then
and they continue to press forward they
look like a bully because it is a
bullying tactic you don't ask people to
talk about things they don't know about
you don't ask a seventh grader did you
calculus unless there are genius seventh
grader that you don't ask them to do
like college calculus and if you went to
them and you said you don't know
calculus then the kid said you're right
I don't and you kept saying well you
still don't know calculus
then you know you're an idiot and that's
that that's the whole point wait till
the kid learns calculus and then you can
discuss the the vagaries of derivatives
macat what what piers did there one of
the things he did in the in the debate
is he took out a he took out a letter
from Ronald Reagan when he said Ronald
Reagan was Ford the assault weapons ban
now I'll admit I have no clue what he
was talking about I didn't know about
that letter now I know I've done the
research what he was talking about was a
different assault weapons ban was
talking about fully automatic weapons in
any case the he pulled out this letter
and I had no clue what he was talking
about it was out of left field to me it
was like complete blank
and I said to him piers I don't know
what you're talking about he said well
I've got it right here I said why don't
you read it to me because I knew he was
gonna read it to me anyway so he
proceeded to read it to me
and at the end of it I said so and that
was the end of the point which brings us
to the seventh point which is don't
force yourself to lump yourself in with
people who you don't have to agree with
all the time you're an individual you
don't have to mirror the Republican
party platform if you don't agree with
the Republican party platform you don't
have to defend george w bush if george w
bush is wrong you don't have to agree
with Ronald Reagan on everything who's a
wonderful president he wasn't to God we
get trapped into this way too much
this happened with Bush a lot with Bush
which would spend too much money and
then you'd find yourself debating why
it's okay for Bush to spend a lot of
money the answer is it wasn't okay for
Bush to spend a lot of money it's easy
for them to trap us with this you see
they tried to do it on Benghazi too
right they tried to say well you know
there were intelligence failures during
the Bush administration well the answer
to that is okay so how does that justify
intelligence failures now first of all
we can argue whether you know whether
it's the same degree we can argue
whether it's the same kind we can argue
if it was ignored we can argue all of
these things but that is in a relevant
point it has nothing to do with what
we're talking about right now and that
is a very important thing don't get
sucked into defending positions that you
don't agree with and that you're not
comfortable with the seventh point here
is sorry the eighth point here actually
is um let the other side have victories
that don't mean anything this is this is
a fun thing to do and it works really
well it makes you look moderate during
the debate with peers there was there's
a point where we're peers says to me I
say to him
everybody wants it there's no problem I
don't understand what your point is why
do you want to take guns away from 300
million law-abiding Americans everybody
wants good people to have guns
nobody wants bad people to have guns
let's try and figure out the best way to
make that happen and he went to and this
is smart
he immediately went to Adam Lanza's mom
was she good or bad and I said well I
don't know her I don't know if she's
good or bad and I said I said I don't
know she's got her bad she was
irresponsible he said I bet you said it
was good versus bad I said you know what
piers you're right you're right I
misspoke it's responsible versus
irresponsible so you could see it on the
tape piers kind of puffed out his chest
a little bit and then you realized about
half a second later that I hadn't given
him anything that there was no win there
it was a semantic win it's okay to give
them semantic wins it makes you look
reasonable the fact is I was wrong I
should have said irresponsible versus
responsible I shouldn't have said good
versus bad because good versus bad can
be taken it's too vague I mean there's a
difference between a bad call than
Hitler I mean bad can be used in many
different senses so it was it was
something that I was willing to hand him
because it wasn't a win for him and
that's something that we can do on a on
a frequent basis the left does this all
the time you know Obama trots out John
Boehner and says we just had a meeting
look what a bipartisan I am he's not
handing John Boehner a victory in a
certain sense he is because he's
elevating John Boehner to the power of
the presidency by having these
one-on-one conversations and it appeals
to John Boehner is ego and that's why
John Boehner is no longer doing these
things but John Boehner you know he
doesn't get a win out of that Obama gets
the win because then he gets to come out
and say look what a bipartisan guy I am
look at this I was in the room with
these folks and we had a nice
conversation and then I told him he was
a jackass and I and I and I threw him
out right and what am i partisan guy I
mean that's what he did during his
inaugural I mean his inaugural was we're
gonna reach out to the other side we're
gonna try to make things happen and if
things don't happen then that's their
fault thank thank you thank you for that
bipartisanship but he's smart he
understands the tactic it's something
that we ought to be doing at the same
time hand them victories that mean
nothing it's fine you can do that and
not feel bad about it
the ninth point here is to try and
reverse the polarity as fast as possible
in the situation when I was on with
piers piers is the host I am the guest
within three minutes I was asking piers
the questions that is the way to do this
thing
okay every time we go on with George
Stephanopoulos people on our side of the
aisle he's a bully George Stephanopoulos
is a massive bully he's one of the
biggest bullies in America nobody sees
him that way because of his boyish good
looks and youthful charm but but George
Stephanopoulos is a massive bully he was
in the Clinton war room and now he
pretends that he's an objective
journalist so they he can Ram his agenda
down everybody's throat that's what
George Stephanopoulos does that's his
entire stick instead of going in there
and playing on his terms and playing on
his terms we need to reverse the
polarity his polarity is I'm objective
you're not objective I'm gonna ask you
questions and make you look horrible and
you're going to sit there and let me
make you look horrible because I'm the
host and you're the questioner well we
ought to be doing with people like
George Stephanopoulos is walk in before
he says anything say George look I'm
really excited to be here I'm really
happy to be here you know thank you for
giving me access to you and your
audience really appreciate it before we
get started I just want I just want to
point something out to the audience I'm
conservative I say it openly I'm a
conservative George you're a liberal
masquerading is an objective journalist
you're somebody who was in the Clinton
war room you're somebody who takes
talking points from the Obama
administration so we can have a
perfectly nice and civil conversation
but I want our bias he's out on the
table at the outset at the outset people
need to know that if I am questioning
the premise of your question that's not
because I'm being combative it's because
you're coming from the opposite
political viewpoint of mine and is a
perfectly fair tactic to do this Newt
Gingrich did this during the debates and
it worked beautifully it was actually
his finest moment during the
presidential debates when he would go
after the questioner that was the stuff
that Newt was doing the best right
that's what made people like Newt I mean
that really and and that is what we
ought to be doing reverse the polarity
they are not in control and if you think
that the audience is stacked against you
if you think that it's really gonna be
so stacked that there's no way to
overcome it don't go
not every camera is an opportunity okay
you don't have to be the Kim Kardashian
of politics not every time there's a
camera out there you have to run to it I
had it was interesting Piers asked me on
to his show after this whole thing
happened he asked me on again via
Twitter he was trying to pressure me
into coming on for a rematch and he said
I want to have you know an even debate
this time I said this time I tweeted him
back said this time I thought it was one
one last time it's about as even as you
can get is this gonna be one-on-one and
he said no it's not gonna be one-on-one
and I said oh so I accused you of you
know standing on the graves of the kids
at Sandy Hook and your response is to
actually bring like victims from Sandy
Hook here to use as a club against me
that's what you're going to do now when
he said yeah that's woman need it and I
said that's okay with me as long as I
get one-on-one time with you all I
wanted was a guarantee that I would get
30 seconds with him so that I could
point out the tactic that he was using
now it would have been imagistic Aleve
Airy bad for me to be on with these
victims not because we can't have a
discussion with the victims but because
it is gauche and disgusting and
disreputable that the left main tactic
is trotting out victims as though they
are experts on issues you do not debate
with someone who is anytime of grief
okay there have been people in my
families who have died it is not that my
aunt IED when she was 42 of breast
cancer didn't make me an expert on
prevention of breast cancer or treatment
of breast cancer and it would've been
disgusting if a politician had trotted
me out as someone who now had great
expertise on the subject of cancer just
because you're victimized by a situation
doesn't make you an expert what the left
does is trot those people out anyway
because the left understands it's an
emotional argument not a real argument
you're going to lose that I was willing
to take that hit in order to get another
in order to let people know what piers
was doing because it was just that bad
but if it's gonna be stacked against you
don't walk in the door I was not gonna
go in there for a stalinist shame
festival where I go in there and I'm
confronted with a bunch of victims of
Sandy Hook and then have them yell at me
I'm happy to be their pinata if it would
make them feel better
I really am it's their choice to be
there its peers this choice to abuse
them and to misuse them it is the
media's choice to trot these people out
there the ones issuing the invitations
tenth point is is maybe the most
important one of all body language
matters in all of this it really matters
it sounds trite but it's true in the
debate with peers he was up on me you
know he was up on the on the desk he was
clearly angry his face was angry I was
sitting back and I you know open hands
and some of that's conscious some of
it's not I was comfortable I was having
a good time I'll be honest but but when
it comes to body language too many on
our side of the aisle don't understand
the importance of it so you'll see folks
and they're there on TV and they're
sitting forward and they're hunched over
John McCain had horrible body language
it was one of the reasons he lost
he always looked like he was either on
the attack or about to get attacked and
there was no in-between and part of that
was because of his injuries but part of
that is because that's sort of who John
is is a human being we need to work on
imagistic imagistic s'matter my last
book was about TV
the left understands this they
understand that imagistic s'matter x'
they understand that all of this what
people see is what they believe this is
why the left wins if it were down to
peer reason we'd never lose an election
as it is it's astonishing to me we ever
win elections as bad as this stuff is
yeah you know as we are at this stuff
okay that so those are kind of the ten
points so to recap really quickly frame
your opponent frame the debate set up a
fill set up all the philosophical
inconsistencies with your opponent's
positions and then exploit them force
them to defend the points that they say
they defend because there's not a
leftist alive in government who's going
to tell you the truth about what they
really believe dianne feinstein doesn't
want to take some of your guns she wants
you take all of your guns she can't
explain why she doesn't want to take all
of your guns that's something she should
be forced to defend please explain
senator Feinstein why this gun but not
this gun should be banned don't get
sidetracked by their attempts to
sidetrack you that's number four don't
get intimidated by them which is
probably the most important one as
Andrew used to say walk toward the fire
if you don't know something admit it
that's number six number seven let the
other side have those victories that
don't mean anything because it makes you
look like you're moderate and like
you're reasonable and they don't mean
anything and if you're wrong you should
admit it because that's that is the
reasonable thing to do if you're wrong
on something just spit it out there
admit it it works for Obama if Obama can
admit up front that he used to do
cocaine and that doesn't have any impact
it's not gonna hurt you if you say that
somebody is right on an argument and
they used to be wrong number eight is
don't get sucked in by that by that
paradigm
don't make don't let them force you to
defend somebody else's position that you
don't believe in you don't have to
defend it it's not your job to defend it
you're an individual not a member of a
group you're a conservative but if you
don't believe certain things don't
bother to defend it because you're not
gonna be a good spokesperson for
something that you don't believe number
nine is reverse the polarity make sure
that those positions that they want to
take don't buy into that and number ten
is the body language thing you know
train it'sit's something that's
worthwhile now why why Mitt Romney lost
the 2012 election it's because of the
bullying on a fundamental level it's
because of the bullying and
because the right does not get it and
MIT Romney did not get it think about it
for just a second
how did Mitt Romney try to portray
Barack Obama he tried to portray him as
nice guy good family man good father
seems like somebody you'd want to hang
out with cares about founding principles
may-maybe misconstruing them but cares
about founding principles cares about
the constitution bad president good guy
bad president that was the that was the
picture that romney was painting and you
know what he succeeded in painting that
picture he did by the end of the
election cycle people kind of understood
that obama was the first choice out of
default but not because he was a great
president i don't know that many people
unless you're like a hardcore DNC person
who's building a statue of them in your
home then you don't think Obama's a
great president he hasn't been today
he's achieved things you want to achieve
but he hasn't helped the American people
the picture that Obama painted of Mitt
Romney had nothing to do with policy the
picture he painted of him was the worst
person since Mussolini right this is a
guy who straps dogs to the top of cars
this is a guy who forcibly cuts the hair
of gay kids when he's in high school
this is the type of guy who will put
y'all back in Chains this is the type of
person who has binders full of women
because he hates them this is the type
of guy who agrees with Todd akin that
there are magic uteruses that reject
that reject the genetic material of
rapists this is the type of guy who
really wouldn't fire somebody just
deliberately so that you know for fun
because maybe hopefully their wife will
get cancer and die right that's the type
of guy that Mitt Romney is according to
the Obama campaign now imagine that
you're coming to this election knowing
nothing about either of the candidates
that's all you know just those two
things who are you gonna vote for of
course you're gonna vote for Obama you'd
rather vote for the guy who is not evil
than the guy who is evil and here's the
thing Mitt Romney did not understand
this he didn't understand this because
here's the logic by portraying Barack
Obama as a reasonable human being and
then having Barack Obama portray him as
a racist Mitt Romney's case was that a
reasonable person was considering him a
racist do you see that logic right he
was saying that Obama was reasonable and
Obama was calling him a racist so by
treating Obama with civility he was
actually lending credence to the charges
that Obama was making against him on a
personal character
we cannot win like that the fact is that
our enemies in this debate and they are
enemies because they are fighting
against constitutional principles and
they're not interested in constitutional
principles and when they engage in
tactics like this that is those tactics
are disgusting those tactics are not
they should not be part of the realm of
normal political discourse the fact that
we allow them to and then we go on their
shows and treat them like normal human
beings this is once you once you see
this once you see what they're doing it
can't be unseen you'll see it everywhere
now when you watch the media and you see
the questions they're asking you will
see underneath there is a patina of
character assassination always there's
not a single question that they're
asking where underneath it's not
character assassination when David
Gregory is brandishing a magazine on
national television he's saying to Wayne
LaPierre you don't care the kids were
killed in Sandy Hook that's what he's
doing when you see Barack Obama saying
you know these these Republicans they
just don't understand how their economic
policy works what he's really saying is
they stand for rich people they hate
poor people here's the fact unless we
start labeling our opponents who they
are they're going to continue to win we
have to punch back twice as hard
civility is not the answer civility is
what loses elections it may win you the
moral high ground but good luck on the
moral high ground as that as the tide
rises because the tide of liberalism is
rising it is not in retreat and the only
way to force it into retreat it's not
going to be sufficient anymore to do as
William F Buckley said and standeth wort
the rails of history shouting stop guess
what those rails of history there's a
train on them and there and the Train is
coming and it's going to hit us the only
way to fight that train is to have a
train moving precisely the same speed or
faster in the opposite direction will
there be a crash sure but at least it'll
derail them and that's the whole point
thanks so much
try not to flash my pearly whites
we will be glad to take questions if you
will wait for Andrew and the microphone
it will be appreciated for the recording
of the events here in the room first
question just a moment Mike that was a
great great dad talk you know one of my
pet peeves regarding this whole topic of
bullying and how you say the Left mixes
is the morning joke on MSNBC here we
have a conservative supposedly who is
undermining everything we support you
know making it sound like we are morally
deficient people and that he wishes we
would see the light what do you make of
that
you know Joe Scarborough panelist for
panders for cash sway does for a living
me honestly and enjoy and he's not
conservative no I mean and we should be
calling him out on that I mean if he
wants to start acting like a
conservative then he can start acting
like a conservative if he wants to
engage in character assassination in
order to push a liberal agenda so that
he makes 8 million dollars a year from
MSNBC he can do that too those are the
two choices he doesn't get to sit there
and play honest conservative while
ripping on every conservative principle
that he comes across but here's the
here's the truth I don't mind MSNBC as
much as I'm on CNN I actually like MSNBC
being that this is the difference in us
in them I want more of their voices
heard because the more I hear of them
the worse they sound the more that there
is a lawrence o'donnell out there when
more there's a chris matthews who looked
like he just woke up five seconds ago
and they threw him in front of a camera
with a wild hair and the whole deal
remember the more chris matthews there
is the better it is for us the more
George Stephanopoulos is there are the
worse it is for us unless we call out
George Stephanopoulos he's the one he
anybody who watches how Sharpton knows
hey wait a second this guy may not be
objective he might not be objective in
fact he might be you know like a
race-baiting criminal whose insights
riots in Crown Heights that kill Jews he
might be that kind of person might
allegedly the I'm happy for MSNBC in
these folks to be there I'm not happy
for I'm not happy for the the folks who
poses
objective journalists to be there and
that's why those are those are the real
targets of the attack don't bother with
with lawrence o'donnell bother with with
george stephanopolous thank you so much
for being such a strong voice for our
shared conservative values I'm from
Texas and there's a lot of social issues
that you know we have all over the
country but down in Texas we're very
very conservative in general I'm
wondering what your thoughts are on
these social issues looking forward to
the next four years in the next election
do we take a Federalists position and
turn these issues over to the states to
attract more independents what how do we
counter that and still remain
conservative in those values and attract
these independents that we need in order
to win well on the abortion issue I
think no I think the gay marriage issues
a harder one for us it is a harder one
because we've allowed ourselves to be
framed into you know the position that
if you are anti gay marriages because
you don't like gay people the truth is
this on a fundamental level we lost the
gay marriage argument 40 years ago I
mean the gay marriage is a symptom of us
of us losing the marriage argument in
general I mean the moment that we the
moment that we said it's okay for
alternative relationships to exist that
have kids and we and we started
incentivizing that and we normalized
single motherhood and more than that
once we change the definition of
marriage to be not about kids right not
about kids the ancient definition of
marriage was it's about the production
and raising of children that's what
marriage was now marriage is the
Hollywood concept of marriage which is
two people who love each other well once
you're there you're at gay marriage
where I mean that the prints that the
fundamental principle is the same
now there are arguments that we can use
on the on the other side to that you
know that we constantly run from this
and I do not understand it people run
from the the incest argument you know
the idea that like if two brothers want
to get married why can't they and the
left just this is where the left gets
into kind of moral indignation well how
dare you compare homosexuality to incest
you're not comparing them you're saying
that the principle behind them is the
same if Mara if the definition of
marriage is two people who love each
other then it's any two people who love
each other and you don't get to make
distinctions right but they don't so
don't get their ways to fight that - I
think on a general level as far as where
the Republican Party is going I think
the marriage issue is is a more
difficult one I think the life issue is
a much easier one I think when people
know that is
matter of Education ones people it's
it's interesting when I was 19 you know
I had my syndicated column when I was 17
when I was 17 18 19 I didn't care that
much about the abortion issue
I just didn't it wasn't wasn't my thing
the older I've gotten the the more I've
cared about the abortion issue and now
that I'm married and you know want to
have kids I obviously care deeply about
the abortion issue but it's not just
about that the more you learn about
science the more you care about the
abortion issues so on that one
it really is even Democrats I think are
astonished to learn that their party
platform calls for you can kill a baby
five seconds before it enters the birth
canal and that's something that we
should be harping on consistently they
say oh well you guys are extremists
because you want to go all the way back
to you know conception well the bottom
line is they're the ones who are really
extremists because we're not the ones
killing things I mean they would they
want to kill a baby five seconds before
it goes into the birth canal and when
they say safe legal and rare like they
don't even bother with that language
anymore because they know what a sham
that is there's no such thing as safe
legal and rare if you want something to
be legal you don't want it to be rare if
you want it to be rare than you want it
to be illegal that is the point of it or
at the very least if you wanted to be
rare you want to set up social
structures that don't incentivize that
behavior as opposed to federally funding
Planned Parenthood there are ways to go
on the attack on all of this but and I
don't think it's worthwhile to give up
on the social issues I think it's it's
worthwhile to reframe a lot of the
social issues in a way that wins and I
think that it is in it is a moral
imperative and our mainstream
politicians are scared of this there's a
character problem here when they trot
out women to say that we are restricting
their choice that and say that we're
anti woman it is not anti woman's who
suggests that you are not allowed to
kill a living human being right I mean
when and when you're talking about late
term pregnancy by everybody's account by
left by right everybody understands by
the time you hit in eight months nine
months this is a living human being
everyone understands that and so that I
mean that's an argument that we ought to
be making we ought to be hammering we
just can't have idiots like Todd akin
making it
James Swanson heritage what should that
Romney have said to Candy Crowley when
she's decided to correct him at the
debate and side question why do people
like George Stephanopoulos moderate
Republican Party debates well the answer
to the second one is them is the easier
one which is Republicans or morons in in
what world do you have a Clinton hack
asking Obama talking points I mean the
contraceptive war on women question was
clearly orchestrated it was part of a
broader campaign I mean I talked about
it in the book two weeks later they were
attacking komen for the Cure in this war
on women
I mean it was it was obvious what he was
doing as far as how he should have you
know dealt with Candy Crowley the answer
is sort of the same as the second
question which is we should make sure
that the moderators aren't hacks and
when when Candy Crowley did that what he
should have said is well candy we all
know that you're liberal but your bias
is showing right now and then he should
have explained what he meant when he
said what he said and there are plenty
of problems with the way that he handled
a Benghazi question he could have
handled it much stronger in general but
you can't let the media walk all over
you and he let the media walk all over
him he let he let Candy Crowley just
trample him and you know that's painful
Candy Crowley is you know would you
recommend that so that our government
officials will be willing to even
discuss or attempt to understand the
Under
well I think that what we I mean what we
ought to be doing is people who cast
around the term Islamophobe are
generally the same people who want to be
soft on terrorism just as a general
matter and that's what we ought to be
saying it's a smokescreen you use the
term Islamophobia apply to things that
have nothing to do with whether somebody
goes to mosque an Islamophobe is
somebody who thinks that Muslims are
just like a racist is somebody who
thinks that Muslims are by necessity
violent evil problematic all of that
that is not what people mean when they
use the term Islamophobe when you say
for example that you are worried about
the influence of the Muslim Brotherhood
in this administration like Michele
Bachmann did and then you're labeled in
islamaphobe how is that Islamophobic
unless unless these people are really
arguing that the Muslim Brotherhood
represents Islam so then the onus is on
them because if I'm attacking the Muslim
Brotherhood my opinion is that I'm not
attacking Islam my opinion is that I'm
attacking Islamism if they want to lump
in the Muslim Brotherhood with Islam
that's a different thing then they're
the real Islamophobes because they think
that Muslim Brotherhood actually
represents Muslims I mean the the
reverse of the again the polarity has to
be reversed we can't accept the terms of
their debate the moment we do wheel is
just a small point been there to me that
it seems to me there's a tactical
advantage to looking civil when you're
in an argument and it certainly Romney
is that's his basic personality and I
think Obama generally speaking did not
attack Romney for using bad terms like
racism and so forth or was it surrogates
so do you think there's an implied
though I mean the undertone of what the
key is we also have to undercut we have
to uncover their undertone so when they
say things like Piers Morgan never said
I'm standing on the graves of kids at
Sandy Hook to push my agenda he just did
it so we ought to be calling Obama out
when he when he actually does it what
Obama in his inaugural never actually
said we hate old people we hate poor
people we hate disabled people he just
implied it and Mitch McConnell actually
did a wonderful job he got up on the
Senate floor and he said Obama implied
that our entire agenda is driven by
animus for victimized groups as far as
being civil I agree we have to have the
appear
of civility and then we have to shove
the knife in as far as it'll possibly go
I mean that's if you read the transcript
of what I said to piers it was not nice
things when I lead off with that that's
not I wasn't saying that and they
weren't meant to be nice
they were meant to force him into debate
and you can do it while still
maintaining the appearance of civility
you can be a civil human being and say
things that are I'm not I'm not claiming
what you go out there and start ranting
and raving and calling them racist back
or anything like that our job is to
debunk what they're saying and I think
the too often we mistake debunking what
they're saying for civility as we
mentioned we do have copies available
and we'll be here to sign them and I'm
sure he'll be glad to talk